5 53 on your wednesday morning got a
teeny tiny taste of things to come at
i-15 and tropicana so you think it's
tough getting through rush hour traffic
in the 95 515 between the spaghetti bowl
and eastern nevada department of
transportation says hold my beer well
not those exact words okay over the next
few days you're going to see
construction cones on the exit ramp from
the south 15 to go west on tropicana
over the next four years expect big time
changes to both trop
as well as the 15 including the ramp
areas that would include replacing that
flyover ramp that takes you from the
south 15 to go east on top now over the
next several months you'll also be
seeing overnight shoulder ramp and lane
closures on the 15 between flamingo all
the way down to warm springs all in
preparation for the makeover of the
entire area which will take places take
place in phases tentative completion
2025.
we've got specifics on the short term
work and the links to stay up to date on
the big picture of ndot's i15 trap
project on our website 8newsnow.com
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone something's driving you
crazy email me traffic 8 8news now dot
com